so there's been a bunch of attempts from
string theory to all kinds of attempts
of trying to solve quantum gravity or
basically come up with a theory for
quantum gravity
there's a lot of complexities to this
one for experimental validation
you have to observe effects that are
very difficult to uh measure
so you have to build like that's like an
engineering challenge
and then there's the theory challenge
which is like
it seems very difficult to connect the
laws of gravity to quantum mechanics do
you have a hope or are we
hopelessly stuck well i have to have to
have a hope i mean it's
in some sense but i devote at least part
of my
professional life toward trying to make
progress on i'm glad you used the phrase
quantum gravity
i'm not a great fan of the theory of
everything phrase because
it does make other scientists feel like
if they're not working on this what are
they working on man's like you know
there's not much left when you're
talking about the theory of everything
biology is just small right exactly
yeah so so it is really trying to put
gravity and quantum mechanics together
and uh since i was a college kid i was
deeply fascinated with gravity
and as i learned quantum mechanics the
the notion of physicists being stumped
and trying to blend them together how
could one not get fired up about maybe
contributing something to that journey
and so we've been on this you know i've
been on this for 30 years since i was a
student we we have made progress
we do have ideas you mentioned string
theory is one possible scenario it's not
stuck string theory is a vibrant field
of research that is making incredible
progress
but we've not
made progress on this issue of
experimental verification validation
which as you know it is a
vital part of the story so i would have
hoped that by now we would have made
contact with observation if you would
have interviewed me back in the 80s when
i was you know a wild bright-eyed kid
trying to make headway working 18 hours
a day on this sort of stuff i would have
said yeah by by 2021 yeah we're going to
know whether it's right or wrong we'll
make contact i would have said look
there may be certain mathematical
puzzles that we've yet to work out but
we'll know enough to make contact with
experiment that has not happened
on the other hand if you would have
interviewed me back then and asked me
will we be able to talk about
detailed qualities of black holes and
understand them at the uh the level of
detail that we actually i i would have
said no i i don't think that we're going
to be able to do that will we have a
an exact formulation of strength here in
certain circumstances no i don't think
we're going to have that and yet we do
so it's just to say you don't know where
the progress is going to happen but yes
i do hold out hope that
maybe before i move on
to wherever i don't think there is and
after but i i would love before i
leave this earth to to know the answer
but
you know science and the universe it's
not about
pleasing any individual it is what it is
and so um we just press onward and we'll
see where it goes
you